this is a Fox News Alert breaking news
rocking Washington DC as two key
senators will vote Yes to confirm Brett
Kavanaugh Republican Senator Susan
Collins of Maine and Democratic Senator
Joe Manchin from West Virginia and noun
Seng their decisions just moments ago
here's a little portion of Senator
Collins a speech on the Senate floor oh
really I do not believe that these
charges can barely prevent judge
Kavanaugh from serving on the court to
that leaker who I hope is listening now
let me say that what you did was
unconscionable so that public confidence
in our judiciary and our highest court
is restored
mr. president I will vote to confirm
judge Cavanaugh the final vote is now
expected tomorrow and what could be
Mitch McConnell's biggest win of his
career the White House responding to the
news with this tweet from press
secretary Sarah Sanders Thank You
senator Collins for standing by your
convictions and doing the right thing to
confirm judge Kavanaugh I think all of
us watched Susan Collins speech it was a
big lead up to quite a stem-winder I
think they used to call him a big
stem-winder Greg it was an important
speech and I wondered what you thought
of it well okay so
she started talking and I started
yawning and I realized that I am missing
something really huge because I'm not
trained to hear it we've been we spent
so much time with short loud almost
trumpian speeches all the time this
might have been the most important
speech I've heard in years because she
wasn't just defending Cavanaugh she was
defending our system she was trying to
preserve an institution and she was like
you know when you watch shows and they
say like you know previously on Dallas
she was like previously in the
government she went from the beginning
to the present time it took us through
every bit of the resistance every bit of
his his legal background all of the
allegations she was a hammer of reason
going through all of this stuff and she
brought us from the start to the finish
providing cover for everybody else and
again she spoke not for Kavanagh she was
speaking for us and so I go to Twitter
right because I see the other media who
were like me making jokes about her like
they came in there male reporters
mocking her and because she's like slow
or sees she's boring and it's like yeah
they made the same mistake I did but
they're even dumber than me for doing
that and I mean they're making fun of a
woman an incredibly brave woman what she
did was brave she's gonna be harassed
for the rest of her life she did she
decided to do it on the merits right so
she was like this wasn't a partisan
decision for her Jesse but won on the
merits and it shouldn't have been this
close if you look at this the media has
been really complicit in spreading this
disinformation campaign here when you
look at that letter that came out from
Ford's boyfriend that raised all kinds
of credibility issues for the media
ignored that the letter from the
ex-boyfriend of Julie sweat Nick the
avenatti client raised all sorts of
questions about her credibility her
participating in some very unsavory
things I can't even say it on television
her history of
frivolous lawsuits and restraining
orders and then they buried the Mitchell
report that had riddled with great
information from an experienced
prosecutor the media buried that and the
media never talked about all the
witnesses alleged they couldn't
corroborate this story from Ford there's
an interesting polling question and I
think right now it was under 50% public
support for the Cavanaugh confirmation
but when the respondent is asked well if
you were told that all of the alleged
witnesses couldn't corroborate forward
its skyrockets to over 60% and then
still things are leaking out of the
story this friend of Ford allegedly
trying to persuade or tamper with some
of the witnesses sworn statements saying
them to change their story this woman's
a former FBI agent the woman allegedly
was coached by Ford on how to take a
polygraph test this woman's being
represented by a lawyer who left the
Justice Department in a huff over Trump
selection who oversaw the hill Clinton
probe very sketchy stuff going on in
Grassley's now alluding to even more
coordination between Ford and Ford's
team and Dianne Feinstein and things
like that and Susan college mentioned
these things in her floor speech too
today she says these
antics by fine scene didn't help the
avenatti accusation definitely didn't
help and everything that these people do
in the hallways isn't helping and you
got to look back at this thing after two
weeks and say the Democrats really
overplayed their hand here did you think
Donna given all of your experience that
I sat here and listened to all of that
without erupted in some form of rage
or began to show my explosive passion
but then again I'm not judge Cavanaugh I
don't get a chance to cry and make it
all up and should only women cry only
women cry that's very sexist in front of
a man for crying first of all I've never
made fun of anybody crying and by the
way I've seen a lot of men cry in my
life and most of the time it's they've
cried did that once after one show
tissue I'll give it to you now because I
can sing right now you were crying
Susan Collins gave her speech did you
think there was a chance that the
Republicans might not be able to get
this confirmation done you know first of
all when it comes to Senate nominations
for judicial positions the Republicans
have only one speed and that is go ahead
and get it done we saw with Mary Garland
waiting 10 months he didn't get a
hearing it didn't happen we saw with
justice Gorsuch he got a hearing they
got it done and three Democrats walked
across the aisle to support him so look
I am NOT going to sit him belittle the
women who have come forward I'm not
going to try to bring back old
conversations about their past because
they're not applying for a job a
lifetime position on the supreme court a
judge Kavanagh should have expected that
his life story his life history will
come up we expect that when you run a
candidate for president we expect that
so I touch you I'm not trying to do
anything no I like being touched I'm
from an Italian family we're always
touching each other
but no one expects to be accused of gang
rape falsely accused of something
leading up to the hearing like even he
knew that his background would be there
but you can't anticipate that you'll be
falsely accused you cannot but you can
anticipate that your past your entire
past not just your recent past well will
come up in the matter of not just
hearings but a matter of investigation
that's being said this vote will likely
happen within the next 22 hours it
appears that they have the votes we
don't know I suggest people who are
still upset people still want to weigh
in call United States senators 202 2 2 4
3 1 2 1 because it's not over the ABA is
now looking into judge Cavanaugh's
appearance let's
compare the two he's not applying for a
lifetime position but he's but should he
be actually practicing law Evan Eddy
we're never after what he did we know
that he's got a great tanning deal
because he's constantly tan we know
avenatti
thank you very much I his makeup thank
you and I am getting back to the being
half-italian that's a gift now a couple
of things the most powerful senator I
think from here on in is Senator Joe
Manchin I mean he's already shown he's
not just somebody who says I'm anti I'm
pro-gun and I'm anti Obamacare this is
for the one of the first times he's had
a major impact full vote as a so-called
moderate Democrat and now he is warble
and you can't get mad at him yeah
so put it this way
margin it's such a narrow margin on
everything that if he's a Democrat that
will actually go across the aisle and
vote on something consequential he can't
be men and if you're a Democrat but I
would say this if I can Dana just about
this whole thing I just want a man we
just have a chance to talk about Joe
Manchin in just a moment so hold that
thought we're gonna get to John Roberts
he's got some breaking news about him
but okay go ahead and finish I would
just like to say this that was one of
the most comprehensive but necessary
speeches that I could remember in quite
some time there were no enemies so no
bad guys the only bad guys was a leaker
we don't know Feinstein I know you never
do that for it I know you were really
hurt
Cavanaugh you've got a great record and
I know that wasn't you so she went out
of her way not to create the enemy she's
trying to do something and
idealistically think it's possible she's
trying to restart she's trying to start
fresh and let's say the next thing is
opioids we make a big deal of it you
just passed stuff that we can do
together because I think we're staring
at the cliff and nobody wants to jump
not Republicans and Democrats so I think
the next time you have me back here is
we're probably 2021 well you will have a
situation where people are making deals
again it won't be
the senator from West Virginia our own
John Roberts is at the White House and I
think you have some you know a little
color a little tidbit about what might
have happened today well I I do first of
all you know to Brian's point I think
you could probably lay a pretty safe bet
that President Trump who's been
campaigning heavily in West Virginia may
not make any more campaign appearances
there between now and the 6th of
November we'll see though but clearly
Joe Manchin was a big part of this and I
am told
let's put it this way I talked to White
House officials after the cloture vote
and I said do you think you can hang on
a mansion and they said yeah we're
pretty sure we could hang on dementia
the reason for that optimism was that
this morning Senator Joe Manchin called
the White House and said that he was
going to be a yes on the confirmation
for Brett Kavanaugh so that's why people
around here were pretty happy today
thinking that this was going to go
through the one wildcard though romaine
Maine senator Susan Collins she did not
call the White House this morning to say
that she would be a yes White House
officials told me they assumed if she
was going to be a no that she would have
called to inform them of that but they
learned of her decision in real time
just like the rest of us they were
hanging on every word she said and we
were here too the way she laid out the
judicial case for judge Kavanagh then
seemed to pivot back a little bit on the
allegations against him but then pivoted
back to the positive again and when she
did that we pretty much knew that she
was going to be a yes on Cavanaugh so at
the moment with senator danes out of
Montana for his daughter's wedding
you've got a 50:49 margin if for some
reason something were to happen he I
always come back and I think it's a safe
bet to say as well the vice president
will probably be around town just in
case don't go anywhere Jesse did you
have a quick comment is it a funny one
[Laughter]
if I were Joe Manchin I would have held
out for more and here's why you remember
Obamacare remember how they got that
through the Louisiana Purchase
the was the Cornhusker kickback I mean
what what did he get I mean I'm just
saying Obama got that through with a lot
of bribes and lies and this got through
I guess I maybe lunch maybe a promise
not in Wheeling West Virginia anymore
I'm just saying it works he could have
gotten more high well I think that he
did actually demand a piece of wedding
cake from senator Gaines when he comes
back from Montana but you know I mean
this is not to say that anything like
this would happen but you'll remember
that two years ago Governor Jim Justice
who is a lifelong Democrat switched his
affiliation to the Republican Party
there have been a lot of people who have
been tweeting me today saying they
wouldn't be surprised to see Joe Manchin
run as a Republican in
2024
she knows that Senate calendar thank you
very much John Roberts I did want to ask
you something Donna I'm moveon.org on
Priorities USA two big
democratic-leaning super PACs have
announced today they're pulling funding
from Joe Manchin who might not need it
anymore in West Virginia anyway but also
pulling it from Phil Bredesen in
Tennessee who was in a tight race
against Marsha Blackburn in Tennessee I
mean is then that sort of like shooting
yourself in the foot well look I don't
know how much money they had committed
to those candidates but I can tell you
Phil Bredesen and somebody who still has
a shot at when in the United States
state Senate race so I would advise them
to continue to support him all right
Greg what about tone in terms of like I
heard Trump actually said thanks Joe and
he said don't mention it
go ahead
I tried to find a joke that would make a
four-year-old laugh and I think I even I
think I even fail here's the thing that
drives me nuts is that to Jesse's point
about witness tampering the media it's
another blackout
speaks that's a big piece of that you
brought it up yes yeah they're more of a
soaring yeah they're more obsessed with
ice cubes they were more they were
chasing melting ice and not this and I
don't understand how they can let this
go I'm interested in Grassley's letter
demanding the correspondence between
Feinstein and I guess catch cats who
seems to be everywhere at once and I
into your point about the Bar
Association I find it weird how
everybody is really silent now about a
vanetti and I'm beginning to think that
even the Democrats are realizing that he
plays a great role in destroying the
Democratic Party because if he had never
entered the picture you'd have just had
Ford you'd have just had one person and
not this kind of crazy gang rape story
New Yorker yeah and I think he's I think
he's a Republican plant a vanetti
he got Kevin Eddy in with that I think
you're 100% right in fact when that
story first broke the story was
Democrats are saying what is he doing
yeah
don't spike the football in the
goalposts right now whatever that old
saying is
what does this mean overall though for
the midterms people on the Democratic
side on the Republican side they were
motivated when it looked like he wasn't
going to get through are they still
going to be motivated
Donna are losers more motivated
because they're angry 32 days from now
first of all there are many states vote
and I was counted eight nine nine state
early voting has already started next
week it'll be another seven states so
people are already vote and turning in
their ballots going to the polls earlier
getting absentee this will have an
impact on the midterm I think you will
find people galvanized both on the left
and the right but we'll go to the polls
perhaps they don't vote in midterm
elections and will decide that this was
the issue that galvanized him to go out
and vote yeah I was gonna play a little
sound but okay so Chuck Schumer this
morning if you could pull up that call
for talking about the Cavanaugh hearings
compared to the Clarence Thomas hearings
if we have that could we play it
damn broke under the weight of credible
allegations that Judge Cavanaugh
committed a sexual assault in high
school in 2018 the Republican majority
conducted a hearing
that made the Anita Hill hearings in
1991 look fair by comparison
well listen it's a bit it's a huge
difference in that story everybody knows
the difference is there but bottom line
Chuck lost and Mitch McConnell won and
it was a very huge victory for Mitch
McConnell just as big as it was for
Grassley just because it was for Donald
Trump think about what happened here you
have a window two-year window where you
have the White House you have the Senate
and then you have the house and the
amount of stuff that this Congress and
this president got done in this very
small window historic opportunity was
enormous if you think about two Supreme
Court judges the victories on trade on
Isis on North Korea on tax cuts on
pipelines on you know repealing the
Obamacare mandate new NAFTA it's just an
amazing is just sweep of the agenda for
the conservative cause and I think
people respect the fact that this
president did not back down that Mitch
McConnell did not back down a lot of
Republicans would have gotten a little
squishy in this situation in the face of
this hysterical democratic and media
onslaught when you you know you're
wavering on on the women vote as it is
and and they and they hung tough and and
they base it on facts and I believe
they're going to be rewarded for that in
the midterm Senator Lindsey Graham says
nothing has brought the Republican Party
together like this has nays hasn't seen
it and he's not somebody just would be a
partisan maybe like a senator inhofe you
know where they're coming from you never
know exactly where Senator Lindsey
Graham's coming from for example he's
upset at the president for being nice to
the North Korean leader at the same time
he's fighting for the president's
candidate while golfing with him on the
weekends that's why I think he's so
valuable now overall a couple of things
happened in the beginning it's the me2
movement it's Harvey Weinstein you don't
wanna be the wrong side of that you
shouldn't be sexual-assault serious we
understand where we should be but they
changed it changed - wait a second did
he do it and this is back in high school
and what do you remember happens and all
of a sudden people that said women women
should get their rights and should be
heard have sons brothers husbands and
wonder what if they who are female what
if women also find themselves have a
male counterpart who find themselves in
trouble shouldn't we broaden this out a
little bit and the third thing was and
this is my unofficial poll is a lot of
people according to people I have met
and polled rank in high school and
college especially when the age was 18
so this one they throw ice yeah well
that's what I'm saying that's when then
one from wait a second sexual assault
dead serious too but I had a few beers
in high school and there were a few
times when I had too many in college he
went and wait a second dick and then it
got to be juvenile and then people say
wait so now you can't have a beer in
high school in college if you have
somebody in that hallway that didn't
like you they become a star now you know
it doesn't matter what age to sexual
abuse a sexual assault occurred doesn't
matter if you were five years matters if
it occurred it matters but it matters
that people are able to describe their
trauma and speak their truth one year
you can treat it seriously
seriously but you also should treat the
accusation seriously
actual assault yes it ruins lives and
not just in terms of public reputation
but it ruins lives in terms of people
ability to live their life and live
their truth so look sexual assault and
sexual harassment they are both crimes
and there were not recognized as crimes
until four or five decades ago I just
want to wrote sexual assault sexual
assault was not was not a crime five
decades ago Seton's irassman yeah okay
separate them oh god like I said two
different as you know okay one years one
year ago after the me to movement came
about not members of Congress have had
to resign or decline the run for
reelection because of allegations of
sexual assault a sexual abuse then
there's been two White House aides who
have had to step down a laugh as a
result of spousal abuse and three
congressional candidates have lost this
session so I just want to say that this
is serious we can't make light of it and
we should I don't think anyone's making
light of it I could just if I could just
finish since you or building on my point
is that of those people they were they
so they should resign they should get
out Siebert Cavanaugh says he wasn't
there I never met her and I think that
side had to be listened to I
know wind zipping listen no one is
treating this lightly what you what
you're doing you're implicitly
generalizing behavior to an entire group
you went through a series of specific
examples and you're generalizing to
somebody who has as far as we know
innocent just because someone else did
something doesn't mean this person did
it that is actually that's called
prejudice when you when you apply
general when you generalize behavior to
Pete to people so that you take away the
rights of the individual that's actually
prejudice that's why this midterm is so
important because you we need to teach
the Democratic Party a lesson that they
will never forget that you don't f with
our system you don't f with our due
process and you don't Lynch somebody
based on some
sterilization just this has no partisan
ring when a needle on the last three
feet he'll come on really when Anita
Hill had to be heard it was six
Democratic women who march on Democratic
senators it was not about partisanship
it is about justice and align a woman to
be heard if you want to make this a
partisan battle no I'm
not I'm not generalizes I'm talking
about an individual and it wasn't even
our
because a Republican president wanted to
see a fair investigation that was George
Herbert Walker Bush in a democratic
chair said investigate these claims
these allegations that is the point I'm
making I'm not generalizing someone who
has known discrimination experienced
discrimination do not like
discrimination or any form of bigotry
either go I never
had a fair investigation if she had
taken care of this when she could have
in August what you see no but I have to
see this is not about Apple which is
also and that's why you do an FBI
background check because the FBI
respects confidentiality is not about
the FBI hands
tied and this investigation talked to
eleven alleged witnesses and no one said
anything different than what they swirl
how do we know we have how dare you
question the FBI
institution
saying no some Democrats walked out and
say we like we haven't seen the whole
story I am saying that we should as
Americans as taxpayers we paid a salary
we should see the report
I've seen all FBI investigations interns
you wanna get that talk about a privacy
issues well they can read a
curse